non-minimalists
how do we tactfully ask loved ones not
to give us
gifts especially those who grew up with
gift giving as a practice
to show appreciation for others well
here's a
i have a pithy answer i'm curious what
you would say about this meg this is
really the core of the minimalist gift
getting rule and i just summed it up in
a tweetable phrase
don't practice saying no practice saying
yes to what matters i think too often we
get caught up in that
in this this position i i know i do when
especially when someone's giving my
daughter these things i don't want them
to give
i always want to say no stop but
let me step back for a second and say
well what are they trying to accomplish
here
it's clear they love me they're trying
to add value to my life right
and what am i saying no stop loving me
stop adding value to my life
well instead of saying that maybe i
should figure out a better way to
communicate what
would add value to my life if you're
getting me a pair of cufflinks or a
necktie
then it could just be that you didn't
know that those things wouldn't add
value to my life i should probably do a
better job
setting expectations exactly what do you
think
oh i completely agree it could either be
in a broad sense of making sure they
understand your values
for example we're really trying to cut
down on the amount of plastic
we bring in the house we don't want to
continue voting with our dollars for
more plastic items and contributing to
landfills where it lasts for thousands
upon thousands of years and
goes into our air and water so i've been
trying to subtly get that across
to family members to maybe shift their
focus to more
wooden or glass or stainless steel if
they really want to
just find a better sustainable option
for the item that they think
will add value to our life the other
thing i suggest
i i'm as a woman i love pinterest
i do i get sucked into the vortex and i
love the organization of everything
i love that is your pinterest handle for
folks listening it's a
i should be meg nordman okay yeah and uh
yeah i have tons of minimalist christmas
boards oh great well let's put a link to
uh
awesome meg's uh pinterest in the show
notes sean
great um yeah so i think if you organize
a pinterest board
as a wish list that way you can have
links from
everywhere you know you could make a
target
wish list or an amazon wishlist but then
you're confined to one
single source so i like pinterest for
that
reason because it can be pinned from any
website so i do like to send
one board to all the grandmoms and all
the
ants and say if you're interested in
getting something for the girls
this year these are some of the items i
was looking at and
those items will be little wooden toys
or
certain children's books on topics that
i think they would find interesting
so that's one way because it gives them
the ability to be intentional
now ryan you and i did we did a
minimalist weddings
uh episode and in in doing that
um we exposed
that during you and i both had weddings
for our first marriages
and we exposed that a lot of the gifts
we got were
rather unintentional somehow i
ended up with three bread makers now i
don't eat bread so that's a bad gift in
general but
three is especially bad now part of that
was bad because
i probably didn't do a good enough job
setting expectations
but two is think about what we're doing
here
we're creating obligation and these
obligatory gift-giving days
it actually takes all of the intention
out of the holiday season and so
when we do something like what you're
doing with the pinterest board
you're you're injecting intention into
it you're allowing people to be more
deliberate
you feel better about it they feel
better about it
it's a win-win for everyone yeah
yeah i mean really what makes talking
about here is
showing uh the gifts that she say she
can say yes to
and uh it goes right in line with what
you were saying um so let's say
that you set these expectations you send
out the list and people still like you
said
uh earlier in the podcast people are
still gonna like maybe overstep those
boundaries
um might pit the answer is this
receiving love is more important than
receiving gifts
so when someone does overstep their
boundaries eat or overstep your
boundaries even though you've laid them
out clearly
you've told them what you can say yes to
and they still
just want to show you love by getting
you something like you said earlier
receive that tell them okay great i
appreciate the love that you're trying
to give me give them a hug
um but you know there's really there are
certain family members who they're not
they're going to do what they want to do
rather than what you want to do and i
think you still need to have those tough
conversations have them with grace
but ultimately the the goal is is to
receive the love that
your friend or family member is trying
to give you exactly
and to me the goal is togetherness for
the holidays
so i have a chapter called presence over
presence
you know yeah and so just be present
with them
don't let your face get all red hot when
you realize that
a giant plastic playset is now in your
living room
right you know let the kids have a blast
on it
for the next couple of days while
they're there in town
you know maybe you haven't seen them in
months because of the pandemic or
because they live 12 hours away so just
accept it with grace
and gratitude and be present with the
kids present with the family members
and then you know when you do your
spring cleaning and you take down the
decorations
you can do your post christmas
decluttering right you could find
whatever it is a really
good home but you know i want to i want
to differentiate what i'm what we're
saying here
we what we are saying is to appreciate
the love
to appreciate the act it doesn't mean
that you have to appreciate the item
that they gave you
but you can certainly appreciate the
intention that they were that they're
that they have for your for your
christmas yeah let me just wrap up with
something practical here
and this is from the minimalist gift
giving rule in the minimalist rule book
um since you mentioned presents is the
best present there's sort of a section
there where we talk about
so what if you decided to gift only
experiences
this year as an experiment right how
much more memorable would your holidays
be consider these experiences concert
tickets a home-cooked meal
tickets to a play or a musical breakfast
in bed a back rub
we did this reason i bought uh you know
my friend you haven't given me a back
rub in so long it's
been weeks and uh
right you know our friend randy randy
kay who's been on this podcast
um she is a massage therapist so i asked
her
i surprised bex with this um i asked
randy like what massage table
should we get so we have a massage table
at home now and
of course because of the 90-90 rule i
have to use it regularly
right and which is a great excuse to get
a back rubber to give a back rub
and um it it was as long as it's
something that we use it was a wonderful
family gift basically that bex and i
it's a gift that
they say the gift that keeps on giving
because we as long as we continue to use
it we both get value from and it's like
constantly giving a gift so i i like
that as a sort of
experience of course you don't need a
massage table in order to give someone
a back rub a foot rub a full body
massage a
holiday parade walking or driving
somewhere without a plan
spending an evening talking with no
distractions making out under the
mistletoe
visiting a festival of lights we try to
do this with
with ella several times a year we'll
even take her like we'll take her to
rodeo drive
and she doesn't even know that there
it's a shopping destination because we
take her there during christmas and
ryan's gone with us before
and just a bunch of beautiful palm trees
with lights all around them yeah
and because it's it's so beautiful she
doesn't realize those retail stores
there
i'm sure she will when she gets older
but right now it's just like oh
everyone's here to look at the lights
right yeah
yeah they don't know that they're going
to louis vuitton or whatever we don't
take her in there
watching a sunrise skiing snowboarding
sledding dancing taking your children to
a petting zoo
making snow angels preparing a batch of
hot apple cider
taking a vacation together watching a
sunset what other experiences can you
give
don't you think you'd find more value in
these experiences than material gifts
don't you think your loved ones
would ultimately find more value too and
if you must present an experience in a
physical manner
print it in a on a full color thick
piece of paper and wrap it in a with an
ornate bow and
ribbons and in a box and gift wrap it
uh to add a material element to the
adventure i think that's one of the
things we get really excited about
giving a physical gift right but you can
gift the the experiences
one of my favorite things it's gone
viral almost every year
for a reason for probably the past five
plus years
there's a grandmother who created she
got a shoe box and she decorated it and
inside the shoe box
is 12 envelopes that fit perfectly and
each envelope is labeled you know
december january february march
every single month and each envelope is
decorated she took the time to put
little stickers and pom-poms and
doodles on them very deliberately and
then inside
were things like here's a gift card to
go play put
golf together you know with grandmom and
here is uh we're going to go to
this little cafe together for ice cream
and so she pre-set up the whole year for
experiences and togetherness
presence and it came in an adorable box
and they can't open the envelopes until
the first of each month to see what
they're going to get to do with grandmom
so they get the gift of anticipation as
well
which is so much more powerful for kids
i found whenever they love christmas
yeah it's the whole month of
what's going to happen on that day right
it's not really the stuff
it's just the anticipation of a magical
being showing up on your rooftop yeah